-Hey, everybody,
welcome to "Corrections"
for the week of May 24th.
We changed the title card again.
We've been trying to find
the right way to describe this,
and it is now
an online inclusive.
We were told, you know,
it's not really that exclusive.
Anybody can watch it.
But it's very inclusive
in that we are responding
pretty much to every --
We've invited all of you
to participate.
You know, all you need
is an Internet connection
and a total lack of boundaries,
and here we are.
Also, I want -- I like this.
A lot of the comments, people
are saying, "Are you okay?
You seem aggressive."
I really genuinely like this.
I mean, the fact that
week in and week out,
I can make myself better
with your help
means a great deal to me.
So I'm sorry if it ever
comes across that I am angry
in any way, shape, or form
in responding to your feedback.
So, last week, I talked
about the fact
that I sometimes say,
"That is the definition of."
And it was pointed out to me
that I should say,
"That is the epitome of."
And then I said
to make a correction like that
is the epitome of pedantic.
And then a lot of you said
it's actually
the epitome of pedantry,
'cause it has to be a noun.
And I just want
to say thank you.
And also that I'm so impressed
you jackals can type in
with your little jackal paws.
[ Laughter ]
I mean --
I mean, to make a correction --
to be called pedantic
and then say,
"It's actually pedantry,"
that would be like -- it'd be
like getting on an airplane,
a guy taking off his shoes
and putting his socks
on the tray table,
and you saying,
"Hey, man, I don't want
to look at your socks."
And then he just peels --
looks at you
and just peels the socks off.
Oh, I said we had
a crocodile smoke a vape pen.
A lot of people said
you don't smoke a vape pen --
You vape a vape pen.
Or to put it more succinctly,
you look ridiculous.
[ Laughter ]
And, look, I'm just worried
that teens are going
to start vaping more
because of "Mare of Easttown."
'Cause everybody
wants to be Mare.
Solving murders,
vaping their vape pens,
and making eyes at Guy Pearce.
This one, I...feel bad about.
I said "shayman"
when it's shaman.
And what makes it worse
is my staff has tried to
correct me on this in the past,
and I continue to get it wrong.
So "sham" on me.
[shame/shaman]
[ Laughter ]
That was a joke
somebody made in "Corrections."
And -- But because I'm a dad,
I'm legally allowed
to steal that joke.
I talked about
our photographer Lloyd,
who's Scottish.
And, you know,
I talked like him.
I used his voice,
and someone said,
"That Scottish accent
is an abomination,"
which is what we tell him
every day.
[ Laughter ]
Like, we know.
'Cause I've heard -- I've heard
regular Scottish people,
and Lloyd ain't that.
You know, we'll say, "Lloyd,
can you get some pictures
of the guests?"
[ Scottish accent ]
"I don't have my camera!"
[ Laughter ]
"Nobody told me!"
[ Normal voice ]
We're like, "Why do we --"
[ Laughter ]
This might be a trap,
but I think it's true.
I had multiple
Canadian viewers told me
that Canadians
don't say Toronto.
They say "Trono."
Like, you don't hear
the second "T."
And I believe
they were Canadians,
because they were very --
In their correction,
they were very apologetic
about even bringing it up.
I said Kroger's.
It's Kroger.
I said Kroger's on purpose
just to, like [bleep] with you.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, you know, we did it
tonight in the show.
I did Werner Herzog,
and a lot of people
said that my Werner Herzog
is Christoph Waltz.
Nonsense.
You know,
look, it's not the best Werner
Herzog in the world, but
[as Herzog] Werner Herzog
would say of "Corrections,"
it is a man's
desperate attempt,
[Normal voice] whereas
Christoph Waltz would be like
[as Waltz] "Corrections"!
It's time to begin!
[ Normal voice ]
It's, like, enthusiasm.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Waltz ] Here we go!
Number one.
[ Normal voice ] Um...
And other people
said my Herzog
sounded like John Malkovich,
which is equally
offensive to me,
[as Malkovich]
because John Malkovich is here.
It's up here.
It's very different.
And to say
that I sound like Werner Herzog
is an idea that I dae not
entertain, sir!
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
This isn't a correction.
This is a-a story
about John Malkovich.
So maybe could we --
Could we make a title card?
It will say, um...
"Celebrity Anecdote
in the Body of 'Corrections.'"
And can we just make that
and add it in post?
So -- Thank you.
So, John Malkovich hosts "SNL."
2008. And he was in a sketch --
There was a sketch
that was written
where it was a lost
Judy Blume novel,
and he was a character
in a Judy Blume novel.
And his outfit was a pink
turtleneck and pink overalls.
And on Friday, he had to take
a photo shoot for it.
And so he wore it
for the photo shoot,
and then he just
kept it on all day
because he said
it was super comfortable.
So already greatest day
of my life.
John Malkovich, spending time
with him, already the best,
and he's wearing a pink
turtleneck and pink overalls.
And then I said to him,
"What did you do last night?"
And he said to me,
[as Malkovich] "I was supposed
to meet a friend for dinner.
But they canceled,
and so I ate alone.
And to spend --
To pass the time,
I tried to think of the name of
every film I'd ever appeared in.
And the 65th film I thought of
was 'Being John Malkovich.'"
[ Laughter ]
"And you'd think
it would have been earlier."
[ Normal voice ] And then can we
just do a title card that says,
"This has been
Celebrity Anecdote
in the Body of 'Corrections'"?
And thank you for
turning those around so quickly.
Oh, this is embarrassing.
We were talking about
how calculators --
Back in the day, on calculators,
you could spell out BOOBS
if you typed 80085.
A lot of people
pointed out to me
that what you would actually do
is 58008
and then turn it upside-down,
'cause that was --
That was the reveal
that made it titillating.
You know, like, 'cause as
a teenage boy,
you'd be like,
"That's just numbers."
And then you be like,
"Ah-oogah!"
[ Laughter ]
'Cause we didn't have
the Internet, fellas.
We had to -- We had to
get it where we could.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
And if the teacher came over,
and she's like,
"What are you boys doing?"
we're like, "Just the 80,000s."
Um, oh, this is a correction
for a waiter I had last night.
So, last week --
Was it last week that you were
on the show, Wally?
-Yeah,
-So, last week,
Action Bronson, who we love,
canceled.
We did not have time.
This makes it seem like,
"We didn't have time,
so we had to --"
But we were very happy.
We said, "You know what?"
'Cause it was very late.
We said we'll have
Cue Card Wally as a guest.
And it was genuinely great.
And I got a ton of feedback
from people
who enjoyed listening to Wally
tell his stories.
And then last night,
I'm at dinner,
and my waiter
walks over and said,
"Hey, uh, tell Cue Card Willie
we love him here."
[ Laughter ]
And I said,
"Uh, you bet I will."
[ Laughter ]
Mm, uh...
Oh, this is
a very similar criticism,
that Mikey the Shoe
sounds like Tony the Fauch,
which is Tony Fauci,
Anthony Fauci, Dr. Fauci,
'cause he's from Brooklyn.
But they're very different.
Tony the Fauch is,
first of all, beloved.
[ Laughter ]
So when he goes back
to Brooklyn, he's like,
"Hey, Tony the Fauch is --
It's the summer of the Fauch!"
And people are like, "Hey, Tony,
can I take my mask off?"
He's like, "You could
take it all off for all I care!"
[ Laughter ]
They'd be like,
"Tony, give me a number."
"You want my number? 58008,
upside-down!"
[ Laughter ]
Whereas Mikey the Shoe,
you know, he's from --
he's from the Bronx.
He goes back there,
they're like, "Get outta here!"
He's like, "Oh!
You're just mad at me
'cause I made it out."
They're like,
"You still live here."
He's like, "Yeah,
but I went to Manhattan today,
and then I came home,"
and they're like,
"That's not making --
You commute."
[ Laughter ]
Somebody said to me...
that I said, "This is
a perfect quote."
And quote is the verb,
and quotation --
I should say, "This is
the perfect quotation."
I looked it up, and it turns out
the way I did it is also fine.
So that's not necessarily
a correction.
That's just an example
of the [bleep]
I have to put up with.
[ Laughter ]
Another thing is, people said,
"These don't --
Sometimes these don't
feel like corrections."
Someone said, "You know,
you should start calling it
'Justifications.'"
And I'm going to keep
calling it "Corrections,"
but you can call it whatever --
whatever you want.
Um, guys, I like this.
This makes me happy. And I --
Again, I feel like
I drifted away
from the joy part, but...
we're about to go
on a week's hiatus,
and, uh,
I just want
to let all of you know
that I will spend that time
with my wife.
And there will be corrections
every day.